vous allez jouer avec nous également
chez vous c'est très sable dans l'écran
il ya huit imitation je sait imiter
brigitte bardot jusqu'à imiter valérie
damidot jeu sémites et jane birkin je
sait imiter christophe lambert je
servirai jusqu'à destin il ya que des
imitations jeunes alors vous voyez je
sait imiter jean-pierre faut imiter jean
paul belmondo et je suis invité nicolas
sarkozy à votre avis qui autour de la
table ses limites et brigitte bardot à
votre avis l'on vous dit non et nora
enora malagré faut exister alors est ce
que c est ce que c est ce que c'est non
parce qu'il est ses potes dans la
tessiture ouest souvent il ya des il ya
des tessitures qui sont proches et la
bouche à oreille et et laurence
activement à l'événement enfin je sais
et mes fesses il les aime et fais ce
leur mort
je ne savais pas que telle non mais
franchement j'ai au contraire fait l'eau
la mfs hanouna tu les aimes méfaits sert
il du coup ça veut dire que ce 3e temps
je veux te faire toutes les missions si
tu veux c'est la question qu'on avait
une voiture héberger ses limites et
valérie damidot laurent pour la sto
lorrain sur un jeu ses limites et
mannarino
pensez à qui je ne sais pas à votre avis
c'est votre avis mais qui savent
vraiment limité s'éviter valérie de
bordeaux a les joues des ou alors essayé
à ces seuils bah oui oui bon à l'oreille
par un pot de peinture c'est ouais mon
petit bakchich a laissé pas mal c'était
voué sa belle mort et dix blessés
vraiment alors c'est toi allez y aller
vous allez les petits chats se mettre en
mode cloud béart parce que la luna est
mûr il va pas tomber tout seul à la
marge est devenue maîtresse des 6 mai
contre un mur elle murs et fournes
pourquoi parce que c'est plus
intelligent qui sème le premier mois je
t'aime dix mois excuse moi ça me faisait
un fait bon vivre au cabba du bon j'ai
pas vu cela me donne beaucoup il ya
toulouse ont balayé la vidéo je sais me
tue jim birkin jane birkin
alors à votre avis les i valérie tout
petit je suis gêné pas bien c'est vrai
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
cl c'est parler d'accord c'est tout je
voulais faire on est là pour défendre
mais j'ai l'impression que ça mais
vraiment tout le monde mal à chaque mois
si oui à la c8 jean-luc j'ai
l'impression que l'on a dit [ __ ] ya la
concurrence qui arrive comme ça
attention je sais qu'il est christophe
lambert qui fait christophe lambert mais
tu nous as christophe lambert c'est un
garde des garçons
aujourd'hui jean luc lemoine alors alors
c'est énorme et le rire de christophe
lambert d'highlander mais c'est tout
c'est tout allez-y en fait le shérif est
pas si mal être c'est normal laurent il
est bon en tout cas ils trouvent tout
petit banc je sais imiter valéry giscard
d'estaing à ce qu'on fait il avait fait
une fois allez-y bafin essayé françaises
français thierry bon alors voilà j'ai
pas mal refaite lorient bonsoir madame
au choix manuel bon choix monsieur assez
sympa s'il est limité le luron jeu s'est
vite et jean paul belmondo
je sais me taire parce que vous en
faites partie ben oui oui il en reste
deux à alors yahoo moi c'est où sarkozy
ou jean paul belmondo à lundi
[Rires]
donc vous dites c'est lui qui ont pas le
palais saint jean paul belmondo série
donc forcément oui vous vous y mettez
jean paul belmondo et manon metz bc hâte
de voir ça hay tad die alone voilà
c'était en baie de la baule
viens donc apparemment j'aï baiser
gratis mon lolo c'est pas beau ça veut
ta porte
c'est pour ça parce que encore les eaux
qui avait un petit quelque chose mais
lui ça veut dire qu'on peut rester une
journée entière les personnes n'ayant
pas le paquebot des airs de petit je me
demande si les connaît vraiment j'avais
vu et vous alors à la spécialité le
combat et l'annoncé regarde écoute et
leur giro très content pour ça je vous
dit pourquoi
au début j'étais pas pour je leur ai dit
je veux pas de l'eau rougir je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que laurent gerra il
a rien à faire ici
voilà c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]